I'm Aleister Bruce and these are the key
moments to look out for in King Charles
III's coronation here at Westminster
Abbey
[Music]
the first thing to look out for will be
the Excellence of the ceremonial
pageantry delivered by the Armed Forces
that will bring the king in his Carriage
here to The Abbey and then return him in
the gold State coach back to Buckingham
Palace
inside the Abbey will be the glory of
the music
much of it has been specially
commissioned by the king for this
service but there will be traditional
music that takes us back to the whole
story of this coronation Through the
Ages
[Music]
[Applause]
look out for the oath the king will make
three promises and then he will sign a
document and it's the only time a
monarch will sign a written Covenant
with his people
perhaps the most poignant moment in the
ceremony will come when the King's son
the Prince of Wales will kneel before
him and make homage he will place his
hands together and dedicate his life to
serve his father
[Music]
important part of the coronation
ceremony will be the anointing when the
king is Anointed with oil on his head on
his chest and on his hands
and this will be followed immediately by
the investiture of all the symbols of
sovereignty and the crowning itself
[Music]